so I've heard you say that you take
every job based on the director and it
would seem that guiding philosophy has
served you well having worked with nine
different filmmakers over the course of
your career who've all won an Oscar for
Best Picture Clint Eastwood is notorious
for always going with the first take
what was that experience like as an
actor on the set of Invictus well I was
a little terrifying because I was
playing with South Africans and that's a
really hard accent to do if you think
about what our tongue does in an
American accent it's like the polar
opposite in a South African accent so
it's like if you say I'll be right back
and think about what your tongue does
they say hold it off big and it's like
what the [ __ ] just happened right it's
something that just required a lot of
practice and I've treated it like a like
a job and I I tested that theory on day
day one of shooting we did the first
take it went pretty well but Clint says
cut print check the gate and I said oh
hey boss you know maybe you think we get
one more and you just turn and he goes
why you want to waste everybody's time
all right okay we're done